hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
one of the most famous ideas coming from
Blaise Pascal's passes is what has come
to be called the wager Pascal's wager
used as an argument for the existence of
God and it's been presented by many
people in in many different forms but
it's very important in order to
understand what Pascal meant by the
wager to look at what he actually wrote
and not engage in some sort of reduction
or summary of it because those often
lose the point it's much more complex
and well thought out than is often
presented now why does Pascal provide
this argument or this rather this
discourse as he calls it within the
Ponce's it is indeed there for the
purpose of getting somebody to behave in
a certain way and he doesn't think it's
actually going to produce belief right
away so that's already a strange sort of
philosophical argument but it does
provide in his view good grounds for
committing one's life in a certain way
which will then eventually lead to some
sort of knowledge or at least conviction
and he says if there is a God he's
infinitely incomprehensible since
neither having neither part sort of
limits he has no affinity to us who will
blame Christians for not being able to
give a reason for their belief and so
this is the background to this this
context and then he says it's in lacking
proofs that they're not lacking in sense
and he says let's examine this point
about arguments for the existence of God
so the backdrop of this entire discourse
is that philosophical or theological
proofs you know that are supposed to be
completely convincing aren't really so
all you need to do is look through the
history of the philosophy of religion to
find arguments for arguments against
arguments criticizing both of those
and that people have found these you
know sometimes convincing and sometimes
unconvincing sometimes the same person
has found the same argument convincing
at one point and unconvincing at another
so Paschal says listen reason reason by
itself cannot actually tell us the
answer to this question does God exist
or doesn't God exist and yet we know
that either God does exist or God does
not exist and he's got this beautiful
metaphor here he says there is an
infinite chaos which separates us from
you know a genuine knowledge of this
answer and he says a game is being
played at the extremity of this infinite
distance we're heads or tails will turn
up a game is being played Pascal is
looking at this as a gambler something
that he actually knew quite a lot about
both from experience and in a sort of
theoretical or intellectual way if you
don't know this Pascal is in fact one of
the people who helps to invent the
theory of probability and why does he do
that because he's interested in gambling
so he conceives of this as a game in
which either God exists or not and we're
gonna find out in the end but we don't
know right now so just like having cards
in front of you if somebody's playing
three-card Monte with you or you're
about to throw dice playing craps you
know what is the number going to be or
you're flipping cards or whatever it
else it is that you're doing even down
the level of just having you know a ball
in one hand and not in the other hand
assuming you didn't play you know
sleight of hand with somebody and hide
it up your sleeve you you don't know
when you bet so POSCO looks at this as a
wager now he considers one thing at the
start
maybe we shouldn't bet anything maybe
the prudent rational thing to do is not
to wager he says according to reason you
can do neither the one thing nor the
other acute according to reason you can
defend neither the propositions God
exists or God does not exist
so don't reprove for error those who
have made a choice not that he says you
don't know anything about it and
somebody could say I don't blame them
for the choice they made I blame them
for making a choice in the first place
unless you know with a hundred percent
certainty you shouldn't commit yourself
one way or another don't be a theist
believing that God exists don't be an
atheist claiming that God doesn't exist
be an agnostic and Paschal says ok you
can choose that point of view but you
really do have to make a choice were
embarked as he says we're on the journey
and you could say well I don't have to
make a choice I can keep my mind blank
or suspend assent or anything like that
and POSCO would point out well you have
to choose the way that you're going to
live you have to choose how you commit
yourself so he says you have to wager
it's not optional you're embarked which
will you choose that and this is where
the the argument actually begins which
of these will it will you choose let's
look at it knowing that we couldn't use
reason before to decide God's existence
or not let's look at it rationally and
let's look at it like gamblers he says
so he says let's since you have to
choose let's lay out what the particular
goods and Bad's and the risks are you
have two things to lose he says the true
and the good you have two things and
he's actually talking about four things
here you have two things to mistake your
reason your Faculty of reason and your
will that part of you that makes
decisions and which is oriented towards
the good for us he paraphrases this as
knowledge and happiness and this is
really the key thing here happiness
that is one of the things that you are
staking or risking and he says your
nature has two things to shun error and
misery so we want knowledge and
happiness the the true and the good
things that are for our reason and we'll
we want to avoid error and misery how do
we do this
okay so we can lay this out almost like
a table with four cells within it and
two options on each side first option
has to do with something we might say
factual God exists God doesn't exist
there is a God there isn't a God and
we're not worried about what kind of God
it is or anything like that that's one
of the criticisms that gets made of this
argument but let's first see what he's
saying
so either God exists in one column and
you've got two choices there for
yourself and your God does not exist and
you've got two choices
what are those choices Pascal says you
can bet on God or you can bet against
God
bet against God's existence obviously
you're not betting against God if God
doesn't exist and what are you betting
what are you staking you are staking
your life what it is that you have you
are literally betting your life on God
or against God
because it's the the thing that you
actually do have to stake so he says
let's take a look at this now let's
weigh the gain and the loss and wagering
that God exists let's estimate the two
chances if you gain if you win because
you've bet on God when God actually does
exist then you win big as a matter of
fact you don't just win big you win
biggest you win infinitely big there is
no comparison between what you win in
this column and anything else that
you've ever won in your life just by you
know the definition of what it is you in
eternal life for an eternity eternal
happiness
so he says wager then without hesitation
that he is maybe and then he says maybe
I wager too much you know why would I be
wagering too much this almost seems like
a no-brainer at the start doesn't it
hey you can win an infinitely good thing
well you know that's kind of a distant
proposition he talks about the
possibility being infinitely distant a
little bit later on and POSCO goes on to
say let's think about this just as we
would for anything else so here's how he
he reasons it out there is an equal risk
of gain and loss now why does he say an
equal risk of gain and loss why is it
50/50 odds because we don't know any
better reason can't say well it's 70/30
or you know 149 to 1 or anything like
that that's not the area where reason
can actually help us out so for the
moment let's just assume it is like a
flip of a coin God exists 50% God
doesn't exist equally 50% possible you
bet on God you know your your your
wagering your life which is pretty
valuable to you but you could win
something much greater down the line and
he says listen if we just understood
this in terms of lives
how would you bet what would be the
rational thing to do if it was a 50/50
chance if it was you know 2 to 1 then if
you're betting one life and you're going
to win one life maybe that's not a good
bet to take because you're likely to
come out just where you started and you
could lose that life but if you can win
three lives and the odds are two to one
it's actually your rational for you not
to bet Pascal says because you have a
greater chance of winning though you
don't have a greater chance of winning
the payoff is greater rather so he says
you would be imprudent when you're
forced to play not to chance your life
to gain 3 at a game
where there's equal loss equal risk of
loss and gain Laney says listen what
we're talking about here is an eternity
of life and happiness so if there were
an infinity of chances of which only one
would be for you you would still be
right in wagering one to win two and you
would act stupidly being obliged to play
by refusing to stake one life against
three at a game in which out of an
infinity of chances there is one for you
if there were an infinity of an
infinitely happy life to gain he does
use that phrase an infinity of an
infinitely happy life to gain says
that's that's what the case is that's
what we're assuming here if God does
exist so it makes sense to engage in
this wager he also says what are you
actually risking by comparison to the
infinity whatever loss you're going to
incur if God doesn't exist is finite
it's almost nothing it's almost like you
get to gamble you get to buy a ticket
for nothing that could have an infinite
payoff now there is a downside to this
what if God doesn't exist well then we
could think of how you're going to live
your life because it's not just about
believing it's about behaving and you
would have some sort of finite loss you
can't you know say break the Ten
Commandments go around sleeping with
everybody else's spouses lying cheating
stealing killing people but that's a
finite loss as a matter of fact towards
the end
Pascal actually considers this he says
what harm is going to befall you in
taking this side you will be faithful
honest humble grateful generous a
sincere friend truthful why because you
actually want to behave as if God exists
and if God cares about your behavior
certainly you will not have those
pleasures of glory and luxury but will
you not have others he says I tell you
you will thereby gain in this life
now we might say okay Paschal you're
overselling that part you've got to pass
up a lot of creature comforts and a lot
of fun stuff if you actually want to
behave like a Christian and you know bet
on God existing so maybe let's call this
finite loss what if you bet on God not
existing and you're right about that God
doesn't exist finite gain you get to
sleep in on Sunday or Saturday or
whatever the Sabbath happens to be for
whatever church you're talking about you
can violate certain moral norms you you
don't have to follow certain dietary
restrictions perhaps so you have a much
more fun time but it's a finite gain
it's it's it pales in comparison to the
infinite good that you could be winning
if God did exist and you bet on God if
you bet against God and you get it wrong
you also must God chooses to be merciful
wind up with infinite evil now Paschal
doesn't talk about this quite so much
but that could also if you're you know
prudent gambler be something that you
want to take into account and so he says
that you know there's just as many risks
on one side as on the other so the
course is to play even and the certainty
of the stake here certainty the stake of
what we're risking on this on this side
our life our happiness our pleasure is
offset by the infinity of happiness or
misery that we could endure over here
now he does also finish up by a few
interesting reflections or a rather
dialogue with a potential discourse
partner so he says we've demonstrated
this you know our proposition is of
infinite force when there is the finite
to stake in a game where there are equal
risks of gain and loss and the infinite
to gain he says this is demonstrable
this is a proof
and if men are capable of any truths
this is one so his dialogue partner says
to him then all right I admit that
you're right about this is there any way
that I could actually flip the cards
over and see what the faces of the cards
are I want to hedge my bets a little bit
I want to get some insider knowledge
about what the gamble is and Pascal says
yes Scripture and the rest and he says
but I have my hands tied in my mouth
closed I'm forced to wager I'm not free
I'm not released and I am made so I
cannot believe what then would you have
me to do so Pascal here says well
there's a bunch of different things you
can do you can look at other people who
are stuck in this same situation making
an equal wager look at their lives think
about whether it makes sense for them to
do what they're doing
you can try to convince yourself he says
not by increase of proofs of God but by
the abatement of your passions so what
we would nowadays call emotional
management or developing some sort of
augmented emotional intelligence would
help you to sort this out a little bit
better and understand why it makes even
more sense to pick one side over the
other so this is the fullness of
Pascal's presentation of the wager you
notice that it's not quite so simple as
just saying well you should bet on God
because you know infinite good versus
infinite misery and only finite goods
there's more involved here reason at the
very beginning has been sort of put
aside a 50/50 odds have been established
but Pascal also has an other another
argument in his pocket even if it's not
50/50 but say 90 10 or you know even if
there's just a infinitely small chance
the prospect of infinite happiness seems
to a way that and he's this is nested
within a larger conception of how it is
that we rationally chew
we're to commit our lives one way or the
other so this is genuinely poss Cal's
wager
you